For the first one, you need to type y, the caret key, the negative symbol and
then 5. For the second expression, we'll start by entering z, the caret symbol
and then 6. Remember this caret will move our cursor bar from the main line up
into the exponent position. We hit the right arrow key to continue back down to
the main line, then we type a plus sign, then number 3, and the variable x. To
get this exponent of 3, we type our carrot symbol and then the number 3. Our
cursor bar would be here at this point, so we need to move it back down to the
main line, so we hit the right arrow key. And we finish out by typing y, the
arrow key, and then the number 3. For the last expression, we start by typing in
the negative sign and then a forward slash. The forward slash will create two
empty spots for the numerator and the denominator. To get our numerator we
simply type 5y, the carat key, and the number 2. At this point a cursor bar will
be in the exponent position. We hit the right arrow key once, which will send
our cursor bar back down to the main line of the numerator. To move into the
denominator, we hit the right arrow key one more time. Now that our cursor bar
is down to the denominator, we type 8 to get our full fraction. Now that we have
our fraction, we need to move our cursor bar out of it, we hit the right arrow
key one more time and then we can enter in the plus sign x the caret key and the
number three. This will gove us our second term. Our cursor bar would be here,
so we hit the right arrow key to get back to the main line and then we type the
plus sign and 2. This gives us our full expression.